It's odd that I've written two novels
out of 12 about Americans who leaves
this country and go and live in Canada
and stayed there.
Um,
although,
uh,
the characters who do that are very
different and their reasons for doing so
are also different.
Uh,
the reasons are political and the case
of Johnny,
we'll write the narrative of a
peripheral and meaning.
Um,
he does hate this country.
That's not the case for Danny Boucher.
Lupo and his dad,
they're fugitives.
They're running away.
It's not their choice,
uh,
to go to Canada.
Although it does become Danny's choice
to stay.
Um,
I couldn't do that.
I couldn't do it primarily as a writer.
I think if I'm going to continue to pick
on my country in some way as a writer,
uh,
I better live here.
I better be here firsthand.
I'm not as an expatriate.
Um,
so I would disagree with the Ketchum
character,
uh,
in last night in twisted river when he
tells Danny that he should leave the
country and stay away.
Uh,
I,
I would disagree with that.
Um,
in my case,
in my case to,
unlike Danny,
I have three children and four
grandchildren.
I'm not going anywhere.
Um,
I live part time in Toronto because my
wife is Canadian.
Um,
but I'm,
uh,
I'm an American and I,
I always
will be.
I remember thinking in the last years of
the Vietnam War that I would never see
this country as divided again as it was
in those years.
But I was wrong.
I think,
um,
we as a people or more divided today,
I think back in the latter years of the
Vietnam War,
it was chiefly that war that divided us.
I don't think it's fair or enough to say
that we are divided today because of,
or only because of the wars in
Afghanistan and in Iraq.
I think there are other deep political
and cultural rifts in this country.
A Conservative,
liberal riffs,
religious and not religious rifts.
I think there are any number of
differences among Americans that a
divide us,
um,
angrily,
uh,
and sharply.
Um,
and um,
you know,
boy,
I,
um,
uh,
I,
I really,
um,
have the highest hopes,
uh,
for,
President Obama.
I,
I'm a,
I'm very excited about him,
but he has inherited such a mess,
such a turmoil that
I hope people
will give him time
to sort it out and to undo at least some
of the damage that George W Bush did to
this country.
And I'm,
I think I'm already too old to
realistically imagine that even if Mr
Obama is hugely successful,
that he can actually undo all the
damage.
Um,
George W dot Bush did to this country's
reputation to the way we are seeing a
outside of this country to the way other
people in the world,
a CIS maybe that can be recovered or
that reputation that we once had,
can be regained that good reputation.
Uh,
maybe it will be regained in my
children's lifetime,
but I,
I don't expect
to see it
happen.
There is,
of course,
a lot of anti Americanism around the
world that is simply a hostile,
uh,
and vehement.
Uh,
and I'm motivated
by the desire to see any democratic way
of life.
I'm destroyed.
Um,
but there's another kind of anti
Americanism that we have,
um,
contributed to.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it,
it embarrasses me.
I'm,
I am sick of seeing,
um,
this country's a bully,
patriotism,
uh,
used as a smokescreen and as a cover up
for things we haven't done right.